hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday November 25th 2019 what's going
on how how's it going oh my god it's
[ __ ] Thanksgiving week isn't that
great how exciting is Thanksgiving week
one of the great this is the greatest
week of of the year provided you're not
homeless out in the street without any
loved ones you know if you actually have
if you've built some sort of life for
yourself okay and you've been lucky this
is the best [ __ ] week it's the best
week right nobody's working this week no
but you know it's working people in
other countries they're all working they
don't have Thanksgiving and I'll tell
you right now that's why that's why
there's all this hatred of America you
know they're all jealous they're all
jealous of that [ __ ] week we have in
November when you only have to go to
work for three [ __ ] days that's why
they were always nitpicking Oh everybody
has a machine-gun oh oh you can't go to
the mall anymore
yeah it's called the balance of life all
right you get a three-day week every
[ __ ] Thanksgiving I mean every
[ __ ] November something has to give
all right you can't have your cake and
eat it other countries why don't you
guys quit nitpicking on us you know as
we defend the world and bring freedom to
everybody you just sit there in it pick
all right we make better movies than you
you love our clothes and when it really
comes down to it what it really comes
down to it you want to be fat driving a
[ __ ] convertible on your way to some
greasy spoon cuz you only got a
three-day [ __ ] workweek you know and
then we have an entire [ __ ] day that
just celebrates overeating yes
in other countries I got you all jealous
now don't I
there's no other thing Lorna what are
they what are they doin Germany how they
got Oktoberfest which is in September
for all you tourists don't try to go
there in October it's [ __ ] over
it's celebrating the the coming October
when they would have the [ __ ] harvest
that's actually you know what I got to
give it up to Germany that doesn't get
set a lot huh I wonder if that was set a
lot on podcast before World War two you
know you gotta give it up to German oh
because they already had World War one
all right Germany and like [ __ ] in 1910
you gotta give it up to those Germans
I'll tell you they're on to something
with that Iron Horse you got to give it
up to the Germans that that's a [ __ ]
great holiday they make great beer you
bust your ass all year growing you know
with your broad farm your [ __ ] Venus
schnitzel you know if you're bringing it
in to [ __ ] harvest you're pulling it
out of the ground we're vino schnitzel
comes from what animal is that huh god
no I don't know what the [ __ ] it is
right visit a heritage bread [ __ ] Pig
cuz I'll eat one of those [ __ ]
and when they were done right before
they were gonna operate heavy machinery
to cut down all of this [ __ ] food
right what would they do they would go
out get absolutely shit-faced they dress
like they were coming out of a [ __ ]
cuckoo clock and they would get
absolutely [ __ ] hammered puke all
over their colorful socks and on their
bare knees right do some dance you know
with their [ __ ] wooden clogs I know
that's the [ __ ] Netherlands I don't
give a [ __ ] right and then they and then
the next day they'd be all [ __ ]
hungover hammered [ __ ] hammered
probably still drunk and get on a
goddamn Porsche combine so I will give
it up to the giant Owen Iceland you got
the Northern Lights you know I know you
got but you don't you don't have
Thanksgiving right cuz Thanksgiving
happens on a Thursday which means
everybody's getting a four-day [ __ ]
weekend right and everybody eats their
[ __ ] asses off because you know
what you need a lot of energy if you're
gonna survive getting trampled at a
[ __ ] Walmart on Black Friday alright
it's a great [ __ ] week
alright Thursday celebrating eating with
the Native Americans before we
slaughtered them and then Black Friday
where we watch oppressed people in this
country that have been buried by the
selfishness of those on top trample one
another to get a VCR slash DVD recorder
that has been cut by 80%
okay and rather than white people taking
responsibility for putting those people
in that economic position who do they
blame Black Friday right and then once
we get that out of the way then on
Saturday you have all the rivalry
football games England how jealous you
right now what are you gonna do huh
watch all those [ __ ] jerk-offs run
around kicking stuff with their feet
come on do you really like it aren't you
jealous we get to watch rivalry [ __ ]
Saturday you got the [ __ ] you got
Alabama versus Auburn Ohio state versus
Michigan you know that's a right and on
and on and on and on and on it's gonna
be tremendous it's gonna I can't [ __ ]
wait for this week you know and I'm
gonna wear a [ __ ] stupid itchy
sweater I'm gonna cook my ass off I'm
gonna make some pies I'm gonna ride on
my bike while my daughter rides a
tricycle round and round and round and
enjoy my four-day weekend my god-given
right as a [ __ ] overeaten American
alright and I welcome all you [ __ ]
people just like the Statue of Liberty
come over here and participate as long
as you can get over that wall that we're
building come on over bring a plate
DUI on Wednesday I will have my new
record for not boozing since I started
boozing way back in 1985
you know when the jeans were stone
washed your hair was blown out and there
was no such thing as alcohol yeah I
think Alcoholics Anonymous
well the Betty Ford Clinic I think was
only about 10 years old going to rehab
there's only a couple of self-help books
half the cars still drove on let it
guess that's actually not true 368 days
and I think it's kind of apropos by
using that correctly probably not that I
could set the record and simultaneously
still get absolutely blind drunk and
make a fool of myself the next day you
know because part of me doesn't want to
put this record out of really try to
reach because I know eventually I'm
gonna go back to boozing I think I am I
don't know I'm not gonna lie to you I
miss it
you know speaking of how funny is it
that I'm missing alcohol the way you're
missing that chick he had a crush on
back in high school and he going down to
the local bar around Wednesday right
before Thanksgiving hoping that she's
gonna show up and you should go down
there and you should walk right up to
her and tell her how you feel you know
that's one of the great [ __ ] times in
your life because I'll tell you someday
you're gonna find love and you're gonna
be 51 years old
stone [ __ ] sober and it's gonna be
the Wednesday before Thanksgiving and
that person you're thinking about you
married him right so instead of thinking
about her what are you what are you
doing you selfish redheaded bald prick
you downstairs thinking about a bottle
of bourbon oh my god let me tell you
that burger barn over that [ __ ] ice
oh Jesus see that's why I can't go back
cuz I swear to God I would I could drink
about 16 of those right now I could
drink 16 of those and would actually
have the audacity to defend myself when
my wife asked me what in the [ __ ] I
thought I was doing
I would be like what are you talking
about these this is my 16th & Drink of
the year how many of you had yeah yeah
didn't think so
that's right Turner are you crying you
crying what because she's so in awe of
what the [ __ ] I've done yeah that's why
I can't do it I'm either on or off
that's it that's it and when you're
wired the way that I'm wired you have to
we have to watch what it is that you're
gonna you're gonna point the [ __ ]
canoe wet all right so anyway we're
actually you know most everybody is out
of town this Thanksgiving so the thing
about turkeys those [ __ ] stupid birds
they're so goddamn big and goofy you
can't make one for just three people you
know what I mean I got a Google that can
three people eat a whole turkey without
dying I think it actually you fall
asleep before you kill yourself so I
think I'm just gonna make a chicken I
can't I can't [ __ ] do that
maybe I will I don't know I'm gonna make
all the other dishes I'm gonna make you
know what I need a new pumpkin pie
recipe the one for my family tree is
it's a little bland
I would just like a little more a little
more [ __ ] zip does anybody got a good
recipe they could say I don't want your
family recipe either I'm not trying to
cause [ __ ] problems all right just
send me a good link to what meat the
lift with the [ __ ] I got a goddamn
computer I get a computer right [ __ ]
here right now hey there's no tomorrow
all right wait a second what do we got
here spicy pumpkin pie by the way thank
you to everybody that came down to LA go
on Thursday night and you got to see Joe
bartnik Adam bard hard [ __ ] destroy
in front of me
Nashville's hot pumpkin pies spicier and
better than your aunt's hot takes at
Thanksgiving all right well you got a
[ __ ] recipe Oh would you look at that
it's got a [ __ ] cream top stuff
[ __ ] out of here I'm making that um make
it that I'm making that [ __ ] that I'm
making that thing alright alright okay
it's really care moments I had huh
singing I'm coming out but singing about
the pie that I'm gonna make well maybe
I'm comfortable with my sexuality Joe
bartnik and Adam Barnhart absolutely
[ __ ] destroyed in front of me they
could not have been more different but
they were the same in that they went up
there and they talked about exactly what
the [ __ ] they wanted to talk about it
was one of my favorite stand-up shows
that I've done in a long long long
[ __ ] time and I had worked with Adam
in in a minute
and he used to run this [ __ ] room way
back in the day way back in the day at
this was this building called I was
called the 360 room because I was asking
what the [ __ ] was everyone was the late
90s and it was like on sunset and Vine I
want to say it's the CNN building now
but it was just this rundown [ __ ]
building and that was a shady part of
Sunset back in the day basically once
she went past I don't know I would say
Highland baby Highland Cahuenga
Gower its it got it got real shady real
[ __ ] quick Hollywood Boulevard sunset
there wasn't a lot of [ __ ] going on at
night and it was I for my money that was
an action that was a true alternative
comedy room where by 1998-99 alternative
comedy had exploded and sorry the
wedding ring that hit the microphone the
or I tell you guys I thought I'd lost my
[ __ ] wedding ring I thought I died I
thought I [ __ ] lost it swimming at
the goddamn gym and you know I tore
apart the filter system as much as they
would let me Olivia but then you know
like Jesus Christ my wife is actually
cool about it you know go and get
another was like yeah but it's not the
one you gave me on the [ __ ] day
turned out it was in the pocket of my
sweatpants I took it off because I was
putting lotion on and I hate [ __ ]
when the lotion gets underneath the ring
it just skeeves me out so I just took it
off and put in the pocket I forget and
then I put the [ __ ] sweatpants in my
goddamn dresser and I didn't wear them
for like three days and I finally
[ __ ] got him back on I found it again
so now I don't take it off anymore
that's it it's on forever but anyway he
used to come yeah the alternative comedy
scene I remember way back in the day
whatever that [ __ ] room was it was
right across from Cantor's on Fairfax I
mean it just had some of the best comics
I'd ever seen that was where the alt
scene was and then before it fizzled out
and like else scenes I mean it was like
the club scene had fizzled out until
that created the alt seat and then the
alt scene peaked and then that fizzled
out and now it's back to the club's
adventure the clubs will fizzle out and
then it just goes back and forth but at
that point all the industry was going I
used to see unlike one night I would see
like Mitch Hedberg one night as a Mitch
Hedberg Margaret Cho Bob Odenkirk who
else did I see I mean it was just like
that level Dana Gould
just [ __ ] murdering murdering
everybody's so different so [ __ ]
original was really incredible time but
at that point like it was already
mainstream because all the industry was
there and people were getting deals and
bla bla bla bla bla but this dude Adam
used to have this [ __ ] room called
the 360 and that only I think comics
kind of knew about and this comedian
Cynthia took me over there Cynthia Levin
took me over there and that was the
first time I saw him on stage and I was
just like who the [ __ ] is this guy
absolutely [ __ ] hilarious totally
unique so it was so much fun to work
with them and bartnik at Bart Nicks you
know gonna try to do a special with him
and so he's been right in his ass off
and he just had just you know
barnicke just [ __ ] overhand right
followed by an overhand left absolutely
[ __ ] destroyed I had a few friends
that came out there who'd seen Joe
before would just like man that guy is
just [ __ ] killing so I was very
excited about that then of course
because they did what they did you know
now I got to go up and [ __ ] push
myself a little bit more was just
everything that is great about doing
stand-up and I did like a little over an
hour and still had like another 15
minutes in the tank and I was so [ __ ]
excited because I'm gonna be torn pretty
extensively next year speaking of which
my first gig and next year I'm playing
the Orpheum Theatre in Memphis Tennessee
and I just happened the other night I
was on YouTube and I was watching some
Stevie Ray Vaughan clips if you ever
want to get inspired to be better at
whatever it is that you do watch some of
that guy and there was his clip I had
never seen and he was playing live it
was that time when he had the big
feather coming out of his hat so it was
right around the sould I think that was
like the soul the soul sorta and when
they put out the live album he had the
feather coming up and also I think it
was the height of him
struggling with his sobriety oh my god
does he [ __ ] murder and I was just
watching him and this was this beautiful
theater you know Chris Layton on drums
eeeh that's really cool
Tomic it he had to rack Tom's when he
had him just to the side but it's still
like a four-piece set up so he just put
that the first one a little bit further
over towards the hi-hat Tommy Shannon
with this really cool bass Reese on keys
and they were just [ __ ] killing and I
was you know about half I were in a
second I wonder what this theater is I
went up it's still around or whatever
and I looked it up god damn it
the Orpheum Theatre in Memphis Tennessee
so I was like holy [ __ ] imma be on the
same stage as that as those guys which
is gonna be incredible and then I I
started to look up you know who else has
played there I really couldn't find much
other than their their schedule now I
couldn't really find anything about the
history of who's played there but I
found this
really interesting guy who was I think
he still works they was talking about
how it was [ __ ] haunted they always
say that haunted me he was telling all
these [ __ ] stories about some little
girl that got like got hit by a I don't
know like a horse and carriage or some
way back in the day I don't know what
and then they brought her into there and
she died and that was really tragic and
then they said of course she [ __ ]
haunts the place so I don't know I
cannot I can't wait for that [ __ ] gig
I really can't wait so not that I'm not
going to enjoy my three-day workweek
here as an American drinking Wednesday
night I'll be smoking cigar right
overeating Thursday watching poor
underprivileged people who never had a
[ __ ] chance trampled each other at
some of the biggest department stores in
this country rivalry Saturday all the
great football games I mean come on
England what do you got I want to get
from around the world I'm talking [ __ ]
here what do you got that [ __ ] with
this weekend you don't have to buy
anybody any gifts either none of that
[ __ ] all these [ __ ] Kardashian
[ __ ] getting all Emily's guys have to
[ __ ] go down like regular guys now
have to find like a [ __ ] like a
goddamn Louie Vuitton thing whatever the
[ __ ] they make over there those [ __ ]
people Jew I'm all I'm done with all of
that [ __ ] you know what I mean cuz I'll
tell you right now you can get you you
can get you girl you can get your woman
all of that [ __ ] everything on that
[ __ ] Rodeo Drive you know what I mean
the second you [ __ ] up you're right back
to where you were before you maxed out
your credit card that's the truest
[ __ ] thing I'll ever say all right
[ __ ] that this is what you get your wife
or your girlfriend for Christmas you
know you do [ __ ] this is where you
test the love that they allegedly say
they have about you go to the beach go
to the park or something to find one of
those [ __ ] people that does
caricatures of people and you give that
guy [ __ ] two 15 bucks and you say do
want to make you get that [ __ ] frame
do you wrap it you give you give her
that for Christmas it's a caricature of
me the man you love
that's what I've really deduced if I can
use that word all that Rodeo Drive all
that 5th Avenue that has nothing to do
with you your wife your girlfriend and
it's all about them putting it on and
walking by a bunch of other women who
don't [ __ ] have it that's what that
[ __ ] [ __ ] is all about [ __ ] both
those streets [ __ ] them both I haven't
said that if you work hard yourself okay
there are there are some there's some
old-school [ __ ] that oh okay
you know what I mean there's a man all
right you get to a certain level of
success you got to buy yourself a Rolex
you don't have to but if you buy
yourself a nice watch ladies you know I
don't know what you got what is your
thing huh like I still think those Louie
Vuitton [ __ ] trunks are the [ __ ] you
know all that other [ __ ] that
they're trying to [ __ ] salute Vuitton
[ __ ] umbrella stands and stuff that's
all stupid okay that's just for you to
have in the background when you know
you're on [ __ ] Facebook video and
yourself and you accidentally have your
Hermes [ __ ] lampshade it's so [ __ ]
stupid
you know it's [ __ ] unbelievable you
know what I mean I can't go buy a used
helicopter but I got I got to go down
there and go buy some [ __ ] ninety
million dollar purse the [ __ ] out of
here what the [ __ ] is that gonna do when
the zombies show up am i gonna blind
them with the [ __ ] price tag I'll
tell you one thing you haven't lived
until you tried to talk to your spouse
into letting you buy a used helicopter
you'd be surprised what you can pick up
something used for aviation helicopters
explosive really [ __ ] expensive but
you can get a [ __ ] plane for nothing
you get a plane for less than you pay
for a loaded Prius a [ __ ] plane think
about that
get your [ __ ] license
driver [ __ ] [ __ ] box and go buy a
used Cessna you know you want to go to a
game fly yourself there off we go the
wild blue yonder flying high into the
sky alright let's do let's do some
advertising reads here the [ __ ] am I
here alright alright alright
and we go typing in the password alright
that's not it come on you [ __ ] [ __ ]
why can't I why don't I print this stuff
out be a little more is this what you
like about the podcast a complete lack
of professionalism do you guys see Tori
crew go [ __ ] coast to coast and
overtime that remind me all these
old-timers telling me how Bobby Orr
would do that all the time you got to
look up Bobby Oh Bobby oh I did it was
five on five no offense to Tori crew was
three on three is a lot of open ice not
open ice he went around people making
them look like I do at pick-up hockey
back in the day when I used to play with
my five years career of pick-up hockey I
bet people still talk about me down the
rink remember that bald redheaded guy
wasn't he fun to skate around he always
made you feel like you were on the NHL
Channel um anyway the [ __ ] am i talking
about it what we got
helix hellix you know there's nobody on
the planet like you so why would you buy
a generic mattress built for everyone
else
next please mention all the talking
points below I've told these people a
million [ __ ] times if it's in the
coffee I'm gonna [ __ ] root it hell
exhale asleep built a sleep quiz that
takes two minutes to complete and they
use the answers to match your body type
and sleep preference to the perfect
mattress whether you're a side sleeper a
hot sleeper like a plush or firm bed
with helix there's no more guessing or
compromising just go to hellix Leap calm
slash / take their two minutes sleep
quiz
they'll match you to a mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life for couples HELOCs can even split
the mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side well when you
bang where do you go I guess it all
depends if she's on top or not right oh
honey I can't do it on this side it's
too hard
sorry alright they have a 10-year
warranty and you can try to you can try
it out for a hundred nights growth risk
free I didn't like it right now sorry
HELOCs sleep is offering a hundred
twenty-five dollars off a mat mattress
ordered for our listeners get up to $25
off helix sleep comm / / that's helic
sleep calm / perk for up to $125 off
your mattress helix sleep calm / / h e l
is it's like a [ __ ] heavy metal band
in the 80s helix right wasn't that that
bad well that was crocus what was that
guy give me an R oh okay oh my god Rach
no what are we gonna do rock you I swear
to god that was a song Jesus Christ my
[ __ ] computer's gonna die here what
would I be doing if my [ __ ] wasn't you
know you would think that you would take
the [ __ ] time bill oh we got the kid
proof [ __ ] things so I can't get
these off can i no I can't can't [ __ ]
get the oh there it is we go plug in
this dumb [ __ ] into the wall yeah that
uh yeah that uh I love that song I think
that's why my whole life I want to be a
Marine the second I heard that son off
we go into the wild blue yonder the
Marine Corps playing cards I really I'm
really considering not telling you guys
that I know that that's the Air Force
fight son you know I like making people
feel smart on the internet um actually
that's the Air Force hey [ __ ] all
next time you go to sing of
like song maybe support the group you
could take out [ __ ] yourself how many
[ __ ] stand-up gigs have you done for
them [ __ ] lunatics you know it's like
to do it for the troops you come onstage
and all they wanted was some horse
showing her tits you don't like to try
to tell those jokes for [ __ ] 60
minutes it's not fun it's not fun
alright
simply say for everybody according to
the FBI the FBI those guys those guys
who aren't gonna [ __ ] talk to that
news lady who had the story about
Epstein and all that then all that other
[ __ ] just gonna let that go right what's
gonna let huh
according to the FBI the average loss in
a burglary is over $2,000 well when you
think about how much a laptop cost and
that's kind of a smash-and-grab these
days you know back in the day two grand
was yeah it was was your [ __ ] living
room said and your your whole [ __ ]
bedroom set they took the China oh god
what do we can do when company comes
over
but even so only one in five homes have
home security most companies really
don't make it easy but simply safe is
different simply safe protects your
whole home every window room indoor with
24/7 monitoring for just a fraction of
the cost what does that mean are they
filming me when I'm in the house I don't
understand this or do they just you know
if something happens then they look at
it they're police dispatch is up to
three point five times faster than with
other companies because simply safe uses
video verification there's no contract
hidden fees or fine print that's it I
mean what the [ __ ] is there an intruder
oh no he's just jerking off and he he
was choking himself as he did it and he
[ __ ] hit the window and made it go
open no he's hopping around he's fine
the system is did the system is designed
to blend right into your home no wires
no drilling that's great it's easy to
order and easy to set up usually in
under an hour
simply safe has won a ton of a war
from CNET to the New York Times - why
ekkada why isn't this [ __ ] charging
if I yell does it make the outlet work
wait this [ __ ] plug fits in here I
don't [ __ ] know prices are always
fair and honest around-the-clock
monitoring in just fifteen dollars a
month visit simply safe / calm and
you'll get free shipping and a 60 day
risk-free trial be sure you go to simply
safer calm so they know our show sent
you that simply safe bird calm [ __ ]
outlets they worked they [ __ ] work
how about this one this is what work
this is the one that works no what do I
gotta do now what am I supposed to do
Jesus Christ
[Music]
so anything worse when you get on a
plane right and it actually has an
outlet to charge your phone and then it
doesn't [ __ ] work and then it works
for a second and then it doesn't [ __ ]
work you know I mean how [ __ ] great
is your life if that's what you've been
above well I'm not talking to a plane
right now I'm talking about my [ __ ]
house I don't know why we got the kid
proof [ __ ] things there so kid proof
the [ __ ] outlet doesn't work anymore
now what happens if I unplug this thing
then I can't charge the remote jesus
[ __ ] christ man okay it's simply safe
so they can [ __ ] watch this whole
[ __ ] show all right how about this does
this work I don't understand why this
isn't [ __ ] working it was just
charging the [ __ ] phone
the [ __ ] recorder you know it's got
the audacity to tell me I have a little
battery I realize I have a low battery
it's because I made fun of the FBI and
now they're making this [ __ ] thing
not work is that what it is
try blowing the dust out of the entryway
to the [ __ ] charger maybe that'll
help you about this does this work
are you guys still listening to this is
this even a [ __ ] podcast anymore come
on oh my god it made the noise was that
what it was love it that's what it was I
blew into the little [ __ ] hole there
Jesus Christ it's called troubleshooting
bill alright oh look who's here butcher
box just in time for Thanksgiving you
know not everyone has convenient access
to high-quality meat Jesus can I just
enjoy a [ __ ] pork sandwich sorry
alright
luckily there's butcher blocks butcher
box believes everyone deserves
high-quality humanely sourced meat every
month butcher box ships a curated
selection of high-quality meat right to
my home I hate when they do this they
don't ship it to my home they ship it to
my produces home all right
these [ __ ] don't know where I live
all meat is free of antibiotics and
added hormones each box has 9 to 11
pounds of meat enough for 24 individual
meals or seven meals if you're one of
those [ __ ] those [ __ ] Asian dudes
who when they win the hot dog contest
every year huh I bet they [ __ ] chow
down all 24 meals they just dip
everything in water if there's something
about dipping it into water
I'm literally laying on the floor trying
to get comfortable 51 laying on a
[ __ ] hardwood floor alright alright
pack fresh each box has nine eleven
pounds of meat enough for 24 individual
meals packs fresh and ship frozen and
vacuum sealed so it stays that way okay
you can customize your box with one of
theirs either either way you'll get
exactly what you want it's the best meat
shipped right to your door which means
one less trip to the grocer's my
favorite I got to tell you right now is
is the the Heritage bread pork that's my
favorite thing of all [ __ ] time okay
I don't know what it is
those European pigs but they just taste
better than the the sows that we have in
this [ __ ] country
all right options like a hundred percent
grass-fed grass-finished beef free-range
organic chicken oh look at him go look
at him running around huh all right take
out that one to the right heritage bread
pork breed pork wild Alaskan salmon you
don't know what this fish is gonna do
okay we frisk them they get rid of their
shift they bring it into your [ __ ]
frying-pan and sugar and nitrate free
bacon all right I like a little sugar
nitrate on my bacon personally I grew up
with the right color for cereal sugar
nitrate msg all of that [ __ ]
butcher box is the most affordable and
convenient way to get healthy humanely
raised meet with butcher box you get the
highest quality meat around just six
dollars a meal I feel like we've gone
back to the top of the coffee here the
this Black Friday your first box comes
with butchers boxes unlimited steak
sampler now here's the thing people you
can order this [ __ ] and not get trampled
stay home okay
get yourself some high-quality eating
well alright don't go down there and get
[ __ ] trampled to get the collector's
edition of Connect four you don't need
to do that all right
this Black Friday get your first your
first box comes with butcher boxes
ultimate steak sampler that's eight free
steaks just go to butcher box calm or
use the promo code borough checkout
you'll get two filet mignon four top
sirloins to New York strips plus 20
bucks off your first box
this is butcher boxes best deal of the
year and it won't last long
so don't wait go to put your box.com
slash / or use the promo code bird at
checkout that's butcher box.com slash /
or use promo code burn at checkout all
right there we go and I have power and
I'll back up to 8% on the battery Jesus
Christ I think I'm gonna make it through
you know Dan we almost
at all all right how far did this
podcast am I thought I spent 20 [ __ ]
minutes just trying to set this thing up
here all right
they talked about the Celtics I've been
watching them you know at Tahoe we had a
rough one against the Nuggets kambei
Walker [ __ ] got a concussion how many
times he get a concussion playing
basketball because you ran into your
other teammate I mean it just doesn't
happen that often
I was nervous I thought he compressed
his spine he was moving the whole time
so I thought he was all right but he
they took him off on a stretcher TABC
this stretcher [ __ ] collapse no he's
[ __ ] jerk-offs was filming it what
are you filming it for will you look at
that 20 years I was standing right there
when that guy [ __ ] got brought off on
a stretcher
all right live podcasts review oh yeah
my live podcast that I taped down at
dynasty type right yeah finally came out
very excited this person this is the
review the live podcast was amazing I
can't believe I got to watch you be
funny for almost two hours for free
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself it wasn't
two hours a little over an hour I had a
great time gonna be doing more of those
I'm definitely going to be doing more of
those all right mr. Rajas hey Bill do
you think if you saw the mr. Rogers
movie it might help you find tranquility
[Laughter]
sadly no and I gotta tell you Tom Hanks
if Tom Hanks playing mr. Rogers doesn't
bring you inner peace then there really
is no help for you
I can't wait to I love [ __ ] Tom Hanks
and I love mr. Rogers so that that's a
home run for me that's a home run I'm
definitely gonna see that movie I love
going to the movies I love it now cuz
most people don't go anymore so it's
great you know it's not as many people
there anyways he says I guess it's about
someone with anger issues I don't know I
haven't seen the movie are you [ __ ]
with me
I didn't think Mister Rogers had any
anger issues I watched the I watched
that documentary on him which of course
I can't remember the name of by the way
I'm up to 12% I'd say when it gets up to
20% I'm getting off the [ __ ] floor
here I'm gonna be in [ __ ] traction i
watch the documentary of him I thought
that was great and yeah I actually like
to think that my live podcast is my mind
nod to Mister Rogers you know I come out
there's a little couch I don't have a
trolley I don't put on a sweater or
anything like that I would never do that
alright that was his [ __ ] thing I'm
not gonna step on his goddamn toes but
yeah that's sort of my you know what if
mr. Rogers uh I don't know what if he
wasn't as friendly anyway
plowing ahead here I'm definitely gonna
go see that alright
Netflix Nazi dock dude has Tom Hanks
ever been bad by the way there's very
few actors that you can say that about
you might may have not liked the movie
here or there but that guy who's always
[ __ ] good you know that's not like
back in the day you know before you
could get everything streamed you you
like depended on actress like this guy
has never [ __ ] me this was one of
those guys Tom Mix and never [ __ ] me
over always had good movies who else who
else and then he had the guys that you
know oddly I said a long time John
Leguizamo Charlie was not what makes
anything he's in better anyway I'm not
gonna get involved in that this is too
many too many people Lee Marvin back in
the day
Lee Marvin Charles Bronson Telly Savalas
this guy's never let me down at Clint
Eastwood they just I liked every [ __ ]
movie they did alright
close would I like Clint Eastwood from
the cowboy movies to Kelly's heroes to
the [ __ ] sudden impact was that the
Dirty Harry movies
the orangutan movies Pale Rider
million-dollar baby right on throat
alright Netflix Nazi documentaries dear
Billy yo-yo blitzed Nazis on drugs oh my
god you [ __ ] kid this is this is a
real thing Nazis on drugs there's a
great documentary about how the Nazis
were all on meth now now now I don't
think they were all on meth that's such
a terrible thing to put out there that
if you're on [ __ ] methamphetamine you
can almost take over the world
people don't need to hear that okay
another one called the devil next door
is about Ivan the Terrible a war
criminal who killed over a million Jews
at a camp Oh way I read about that guy
also the one you were thinking of about
Eichmann was called Operation Operation
final oh you got to see that that's
where the Mossad finally got that guy
right Jesus cry was that it was
unbelievable unbelievable
well I'm gonna watch those Nazis on
drugs I'm watching that tonight Jesus
Christ homeboys in outer space first and
then Nazis on drugs it's gonna be my
evening Trump impeachment in a few
sentences oh thank you for so much for
[ __ ] clearing this up cuz you know I
have a tremendous responsibility to keep
fellow Americans not only fellow
Americans informed but you know people
around the world like people around the
world listening right now had no idea
that they had yet another reason to be
jealous of the United States of America
is this thing and really [ __ ] wind up
in it I just unbeliev wires I just
[ __ ] I got to get off this [ __ ]
floors what this is I got to get it off
this floor this that's gonna be named my
one-person show
well you know how it is when you get to
a certain age you just got to get off
the [ __ ] floor he could actually call
out one person show that Beckham when I
first started in this business that's
his thing he's always every episode a
hundred episodes he's trying to get off
the floor he has a whacky next-door
neighbor who's clearly gay but we'll
never address that and there'll be some
sort of Muppet from outer space and you
got yourself a [ __ ] show
okay the Trump impeachment in a few
short sentences all right and I gotta
[ __ ] get down here again to read this
all right Ukraine okay here's what
happened for all you people like me who
don't know what everybody on Facebook is
so upset about trumpet Pietschmann a few
short sentences a few sentences Ukraine
needed millions and aid the US agreed
and said okay sure money is yours that's
not how we do it then you got to give us
a pound of flesh we know how that works
right let us build a base so we can
defend you then Trump called the Ukraine
president and said or didn't say this is
a legend I believe what you're saying
allegedly Trump called the Ukrainian
president and said we the US will give
you the money if you say that you are
looking into the Biden's for being shady
former Vice President Joe Biden's son
worked for a Ukrainian company not
really worked but he was on the board
which is a non job and just the title
Biden's son was paid $50,000 a month
Jesus Christ wasn't for with no foreign
with no foreseeable reason other than
his name is Biden okay did that happen
or is that also a legend that Ukrainian
company was caught up in some shady [ __ ]
all the ones that looked into him also
the shady deal they hired some shady
people to carry it out while this is
fascinating a shady company that the
Ukraine has had trouble with in the past
okay so Trump wanted Ukrainian president
to publicly say we in the Ukraine are
looking into the company
parentheses and therefore looking into
Biden's son for shading deep shady
dealings then Trump said Rudy Guiliani
is going to call you this is all alleged
and you guys are going to make a
statement to the world that Biden's son
is involved in some shady [ __ ] that's it
well this happens every [ __ ] election
this is enough to distract the President
of the United States because he's trying
to dig up dirt even if it isn't there
they all do this [ __ ] anyway apparently
some see that quote I'll give you this
if you do this as a shakedown oh that's
every business deal works that way that
is what in Trump's that it was in
Trump's personal interest as Biden is
running for president that publicly
saying the Ukrainian is looking into the
Biden's where it hurt Biden in the
upcoming election against Trump Biden
could never be Trump why is he wasting
his this is like Nixon all over again
he was gonna win and he got this another
paranoid [ __ ] lunatic
people are bringing up Rudy as he was
calling back a fourth was calling back
and forth trying to get them to look
into Biden Rudy was the middle man and a
lot of the calls allegedly at the very
least it was a conflict of interest they
quote think they felt that the left
think system so the impeachment was to
show that Trump was holding up foreign
aid and millions of dollar oh I see now
okay to help his personal presidential
run next term tried to make it a short
answer sorry I totally understand I
think if what you're saying is accurate
that's basically off so I see the rub
was not that he was trying to find
[ __ ] dirt it said that he was using
it for his own personal interest and we
weren't helping people at all right well
if you ever looked into like I used to
remember as a kid I used to think like
why are we we always give like a billion
dollars to a country and in the end of
it that country ends up hating us why is
that you know and then when I looked it
up I was like
oh that's how when a country gives
another country money as far as what
I've read I read that book Confessions
of an economic hitman and it was
basically that's where I got that phrase
their pound of flesh so when when
whatever country goes to give a country
that's not doing so well money they have
to pay it back somehow by letting us or
somebody else have access to some
natural resources you got to let us
build a dam and it's an American company
it's gonna [ __ ] you know create all
these jobs and then it doesn't and then
they fork they default on the [ __ ]
loan and then we come in a you got to
pay his back and we build a base so we
can air-quote protect them maybe we're
protecting him other people say we're
expanding our empire it's a filthy game
it's a filthy game well you know what I
think Trump's in the right business no
it's actually not true he's actually
brought a lot of shame to the office
that the other great people that have
been in there like the Clintons and the
bushes and the Obama's not Bush senior I
like that guy
sorry advice I like bush senior and I
like I like Jimmy Carter those are the
two guys I liked so far in my lifetime
all right advice both one-term
presidents by the way both considered
weak you know both avoided getting us
into major major [ __ ] Wars both were
considered weak figure that one out all
right a Billy big red bar I'm a 37 year
old single male pictures please I'm
starting to get some weird comments
about why I'm still single well you're
obviously not living in New York or LA
you got another ten years before people
are like what's going on with that guy
anyways last week my dad sat me down for
a heart-to-heart and asked if I'm gay he
said it's all right if you are the
family will
- love you well that's great he goes I'm
not gay at all not even a little I just
had some relationship in the past that
were nightmares most of them were most
of them were to tell you the truth I
just had some relationships in the past
that were nightmares I think he wanted
to say to tell you the truth
anyways also I look at other
relationships and people just seem so
unhappy and I do not want to put myself
in that position or end up getting some
chick pregnant that II do not want to be
with long-term and to end up paying
child support and get into arguments
about where the kid is going for
Christmas all right so obviously you've
seen a lot of failures and relationships
you are now catastrophizing and you are
destroying any possible chances of a
relationship before it even starts why
do I know this because I did the same
[ __ ] thing
so some advice if you would be helpful
I'm happy where I'm at but do you think
I should start playing the field again I
know my parents want a grant want
grandchildren but I just don't want to
go through what all my past
relationships turned out to be all right
well you got to start fishing in a
different watering hole you keep fishing
in the same pond
you're gonna keep pulling up the same
kind of fish it at some point you got to
be looking at what you're doing anyways
he goes also I'm a recovered addict
sober for three years congratulations
and bars are not my thing
help me out here big red thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself
I would say there's a plenty of things
that you can get involved with the don't
involve drinking I bet if you googled
that hey I'll do it for you hey let me
let me do all the [ __ ] heavy lifting
you know why you know why I'm doing that
Hey that's right Elodie else alright
alright how to meet new people without
drinking okay how to meet someone this
weekend if you don't drink alright this
is the first one we're gonna go to this
one why is my laptop vibrating Jesus
Christ oh it's funny though this picture
of the guy waving to some chick in a
suntanned like a [ __ ] Sun chair oh hi
hi that's always a great way to pick up
a chick just [ __ ] cook just sort of
wave at her you know I never tried that
I bet that works just something about
waving you got a wave back how many
times you like this some have been
waving at someone behind you and you
look at them like I don't know that
person you you're still wave I think
that oh my god [ __ ] coming up with an
opening line just you just get a wave
anyways whether dating apps are causing
how shut the [ __ ] up and just get to it
as someone who lived and dated in New
York City for years I'd be lying if I
said alcohol didn't play a huge part
Jesus Christ you'd also be lying if you
said you got to the [ __ ] point
because alcohol is such a huge part of
the no matter why you would choose to
abstain this is literally nine
paragraphs in don't feel like you have
to avoid bars if you made the decision
not to drink you shouldn't sweat it if
someone plans I hang out at a bar
because you're not giving me things to
do alright seek out new experiences get
out of your comfort zone you know
something [ __ ] this person this is just
all generic horseshit all right I would
say you know there's there's sports
leagues co-ed sports leagues there's a
book club sorry I don't know what you
know what I honestly don't know I was
such a [ __ ] drunk I don't know what
people do but that's what I would do
alright I would try sorry but making all
kinds of [ __ ] noise moving the record
around I have to get off this [ __ ]
floor I have to get off this floor sir
and you should go out and try and meet
somebody
all right just because everybody else is
[ __ ] up that's like like having a kid
like like all these [ __ ] parents sit
there and they tell you like oh how old
you kid
be like you know she's two-and-a-half oh
the terrible toes the terrible toes he's
just like no she's actually been pretty
great oh wait till she's three three
days three and Adri you know just no
matter what they just project gloom and
doom I don't know this is there's music
there's there's art festivals
there's the farmers market you know
that's a great place to hit on when
women love to be hit on that farmers
market all right don't don't listen to
these [ __ ] you know chicks that you
would never hit on anyways okay if you
[ __ ] like somebody gene you get some
point you got a hit on it if I don't ask
questions I'm gonna be single for the
rest of my [ __ ] what am I supposed to
do hey I don't want to hit on you while
you're picking out your green beans
there where you gonna be later so I can
[ __ ] show up and freak you out man
white women are doing a lot of
complaining is it incredible it's
[ __ ] incredible you'd never know they
were white I'm sober how do I meet
someone without hanging out at a bar
how do you in Traverse meet people
listen there's plenty I'm not doing that
I I takes me forever to read [ __ ] I
would just Google this find out five
ways to make new friends when you're
sober oh wait a minute
but sober but not in a program are you
in a program well here's one for you
don't [ __ ] meet some chick at an AAA
meeting Jesus Christ don't [ __ ] do
that don't do that all right she's over
there chain smoking cigarettes and
eating [ __ ] doughnuts you don't need
that in your life all right that's what
I would do I would find sir I would I
would Google what I just googled and
sift through it and you know and I was
so I wasn't tell you dad this is why I'm
not in it you know no offense dad but
you look pretty miserable when I was
growing up
all right advice hosting first
Thanksgiving oh Jesus
oh the stress the stress of hosting your
own Thanksgiving what do I wear where do
I sleep people is this souffle gonna
collapse
alright hosting first Thanksgiving dear
dear Billy space Blaster tits oh that's
a reference to the mandalorian episode 3
came out I am up on Star Wars people I'm
watching it jon favreau everybody
crushing it crushing it from someone who
doesn't watch Star Wars I'm loving the
Mandalorian and not cuz I'm just looking
for my big bald head which I heard is
coming up in episode 6
alright see [ __ ] bastards I give you
this free goddamn podcast why don't you
why don't you spend if a couple of
shekels there huh let's just spend a
couple of yen wherever you are in the
[ __ ] world alright God knows England
has their own currency alright isn't
that what the Blitzkrieg is about breaks
it pound French with the Franks they're
on the euro right just [ __ ] get
Disney Plus I'm telling you they got it
you know they got it they got the Jeff
Goldblum show they got the mandalorian
they got all those all those of you know
I'm not a big movie gotta gala bunch of
movies all right Thanksgiving dear Billy
space Blaster tits I'm hosting the first
Thanksgiving this year
which will include my parents my in-laws
and in-laws of in-laws wow these people
have terrible manners especially while
eating these include the following oh no
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh my god let's read this again
which will have my parents my in-laws
well you [ __ ] on your own parents so
like you know they have terrible manners
but we'll where are you
Jesus Christ my father-in-law constantly
talks with his mouth full of food ooh
that's a tough one that is a tough one
he then gets a gravy like substance
crackling in his throat oh my god
but we'll never clear his throat I
people who won't clear that throats he
also sticks his hand in his drinks drink
pulls out ice cube cubes loudly sucks on
them then spits them back into his drink
or loudly crunches them Jesus Christ
it's like a Martin Short character my
mother in love my mother in law's bilah
mother-in-law thinks she she's in charge
and keeps yelling at my son and telling
him what to do like eat his dinner I
can't have that right in front of my
wife and me well that's on your wife to
say something don't bring that up it's
too close to Thanksgiving it's too late
you got to talk about this after the
holidays you got to sit through one more
[ __ ] holiday sit down
and you got to start with listen you
know I love you you know I love your mom
okay
but I feel like we're aren't where our
kids parents so we should be you know
she doesn't need to step in she already
has a mom she has you you know all right
he already hasn't no whatever anyways
she also anyways we aren't the type to
let our kid do anything he wants if
you're wondering she also sucks and
crunches her ice my sister-in-law's [ __ ]
mother that almost sounds like a rank my
sister-in-law has cut mother on deck who
has nowhere else to go because no one
likes her Oh God ruins each holiday meal
by being loud abrasive and obnoxious
she's always snapping gum because she
just had a cigarette and is always
talking about negative topics that no
one is interested in which just brings
the entire vibe way down man all right
since this is my house shouldn't I have
the right to address these issues if
they come up buddy I gotta tell you
something that ship sailed
the second you [ __ ] agreed to have
Thanksgiving at your place without
without [ __ ] saying who can come it's
too late for this it's too late all
right we have ignition the rocket has
already taken off
can't turn the [ __ ] thing around
don't worry there's a light at the end
of this tunnel
I'm gonna finish reading this if so how
should I go about addressing these
people and their terrible manners
without my wife getting angry with me
it's impossible and me coming off like
an [ __ ] to everyone it's impossible
Congrats on your sobriety happy
Thanksgiving to you Nia and your
daughter and thanks for all the free
entertainment over the years all right
cool you guys don't have to congrat me
on my [ __ ] sobriety it's not I'm not
in the [ __ ] program I'm just a
[ __ ] binge drinker that's taken a
little sabbatical here you know Jordan
went and played baseball for a year and
a half right year or so right I'm taking
off same thing I'm in my Jordan yeah all
right here's what you do okay you don't
do a [ __ ] thing but just be the
greatest goddamn Thanksgiving host of
all time okay you put on the most
festive [ __ ] sweater you could find
you kick you [ __ ] cook your goddamn
ass off all right and then you just let
these [ __ ] animals act like the
animals that they are I'd even get them
a little liquored up if you can't just
prop you know prime the pump a little
bit let them act like absolute [ __ ]
lunatics okay this is your only chance
and even then this is an uphill battle
because at the end of the day you're
gonna have to sell your wife on the fact
that you think her family is a bunch of
[ __ ] animals okay and I am not
doubting for one second that they are
the detail that you went into okay
you have to understand this okay as a as
a as a man who's now a husband and a
father Thanksgiving is no longer yours
okay
it's no longer yours it's somebody
else's okay your Thanksgiving you know
when your Thanksgiving is is the second
the last one of those [ __ ] ice
crunching [ __ ] walks out that door
that's when your Thanksgiving begins so
what you have to look at this as this is
essentially a [ __ ] it's just it's a
day you're not going to get back but
there is balance in the universe
okay and you go there you be an absolute
[ __ ] sweetheart okay
and you just let them crunch their ice
not clear their throat and do all of
that [ __ ] and one of the things that
that you can do if you don't like these
people is you could be the person
clearing the table and going in to wash
the dishes this gets you in another
[ __ ] room
right there's also nothing stopping you
at the last second from inviting a
friend of yours who maybe has nowhere to
go and then you guys can kind of [ __ ]
buddy up all right okay but here's the
thing you cannot on any [ __ ] level
address these people at the Thanksgiving
- you think you can't you can't there's
no way you're not gonna look like an
[ __ ] and if your wife is a woman she
will hold this over your head for the
rest of your life now if you're in an
alternative relationship and you're gay
and you abducted maybe the dude will be
cool enough to let it go at some point
yeah I think you just you just got a
[ __ ] you're just gonna have to
tolerate it and then next year you got
to lay the groundwork of being like you
know what can we just say maybe let's
just do one year with just us you know
there's just a lot of [ __ ] but I think
the only thing you can kind of address
here is the mother-in-law's behavior
after after she leaves that's what I
would do but other than that I gotta
tell you something buddy you [ __ ] your
Thursday is [ __ ] and you're gonna get
through it I believe in you and you know
what you know what's gonna be the
greatest day of your [ __ ] week Friday
this is all this is what you do tell
your wife okay why don't you plan
something fun for you on Friday
okay and when she goes why I wanted you
to plug blah you just take her bite put
your hands on her shoulder kiss her on
the forehead look it right in the eye
and be like I need this no okay yeah
just plan something fun plan something
fun you and the fellas and then just
just be just
remembering all the dumb [ __ ] your
relatives are doing and then the next
night go out and get shit-faced with
some of your buddies and retell all the
stories and they're gonna laugh their
[ __ ] asses off and it's gonna be
cathartic for you all right
there you go that's my recipe for
getting through your Thanksgiving all
right that's it that's the podcast go
[ __ ] yourselves and I will check in on
you on Thursday